how much time is a writer's room given
to break a story
um very determined by the showrunner and
their process but I would say in general
it's about a week per episode
um sometimes longer especially if it's a
really serialized show and it's a
streaming show where you're writing
everything before it shoots the 20 weeks
of the writer's room can sort of if you
have 20 weeks can sort of stretch each
episode break a little further because
you have more time in broadcast
television once the train of the season
starts running you have to keep running
too or else it will run you over so a
week is about as long as I think I've
ever had and a week like meaning seven
days
um
shorter if if you can is always
preferred
um but yeah it's no one wants to rush an
episode off the board because if you do
you always end up putting it back on the
board when you go right the outline and
stuff doesn't work and then you know
it's like okay and you put the cards
back up and you're like let's fix it so
it's better to take the time to fix it
while it's there
um another thing that can happen in a
break is that
people different different people prefer
different things as writers when you're
breaking your episode that you're gonna
write
um I think it's always great to have a
conversation in the room about like how
do we get into the scene how do we get
out
um
because that's helpful right it's sort
of short hands for you about like you
know I just need to come into the scene
while they're already sitting at the
table arguing I don't need the build up
and whatever but there's a lot of things
that I'm like you guys I can figure that
out I don't need to talk about it like I
I will figure out how we get out of the
scene like I just don't need to have a
conversation about it some writers
really need to have that conversation
and so you need to say like hey it would
be really helpful for me if we talked
about how we're getting in and out of
everything
I tend to be like I just need to know
what's happening in the scene I don't
need the the how we get in how we get
out I'm going to figure that out on the
page let's just make sure we have every
moment that we need in the scene written
on this card so that I know what it what
all has to happen so it's a little bit
different depending on your writing
style I think
and does each writer get its own episode
their own episode or each episode is a
collective
process very show dependent
um my experience has been that every
writer either gets a solo episode or
co-writes episodes
um
throughout the season so most standard
is each solo Rider gets at least one
episode that they write themselves
writing teams will write an episode
together and then sometimes like in
order for a staff writer to get more
experience they'll pair the staff writer
with a coep to write so they get to
write another half a script so that they
get more of a chance to write or in a
room that has the episodes to do it you
really want your writer writer's
assistant to get a chance to write so
you'll pair your writer's assistant with
a more experienced writer so they get a
chance so oftentimes that'll turn into
like one one and a half scripts per
writer per team depending on how it
works out
um
there are circumstances in which staff
writers do not get to write a script
because the room is super top heavy and
there's only a limited number say
there's
eight writers in the room
and there's eight episodes of Television
well at least the first one's already
written probably because your
showrunner's already written the pilot
your showrunner's probably writing the
finale so now there's six episodes left
and there's eight writers so unless they
pair you up with someone you may not get
a script
but it's still a great experience and
you'll still get to learn lots of things
and what most show Runners will try to
do in that case is like give this the
staff writer a chance to write the story
documents or to help with the outlines
or do things that like give them
experience even though they're not
writing a script I should give you a
little more on that probably too
um
there is there are shows that do all
group writing
it is my least preferred method of
writing a show
um but there are show Runners who swear
by it and if it works for them it's
their right to do it but that is where
literally like you do that whole
breaking process you have all your
scenes and it gets divvied up amongst
the entire staff and so people write
scenes and then it all gets assembled
and you know the share Runner does
passes on it whatever once there's a
completed episode someone on the staff
will be credited with having written it
um if it remains a completely group
Endeavor there are some shows where we
group write the first draft and then I
as the writer of that episode will take
it and do a pass to try to make it all
cohesive and then I will be in control
of the script with the showrunner for
the rest of the run and then it is you
know to allow the writer to take more
ownership over it
um I I believe group writing is good in
emergencies like when your lead actor
suddenly has to disappear for three days
um but I am not about it as a general
rule but plenty of people do it is there
a danger though in that there are going
to be different voices and styles that
are going to be very noticeable if it's
100 100 which is why someone even if
it's the share Runner is going to have
to take that Frankenstein draft is what
we call them and go make a cohesive
feeling episode like it's never going to
be right when you first assemble all the
pieces like it's just not everybody has
a different take on slightly different
way that they like to write this
character versus that character this
writer does and so you as a showrunner
will have to go in and or assign a
writer to do it but you someone has to
make it cohesive so that it feels like
one writer wrote it
sure and then if it's different episodes
that there's also the danger in that
each one's going to sound or have a
different style and tempo
yeah I mean that is a danger the real
truth of the matter is the showrunner is
should I I believe I will say should be
taking the final pants on every script
because at the end of the day it is the
showrunner's job to make sure every
episode feels like it belongs together
so you know you may have a really
talented writer who doesn't quite get
the voice of the show right part of your
job as the showrunner is to take that
script and adjust it so that the voice
feels right and send it on through and
not put your name on it because this is
your job and allow that writer to take
full credit for the episode because
they've done their work your job as the
showrunner is to take it to the final
level
does everyone in the room obsess over
the season finale on the first day
no no I think it's pretty rare because
sometimes I mean I have literally been
in situations where on the first day we
don't even know what the season's about
so all you're hoping for in that case is
that someone figures it out because you
know to me really good showrunners are
prepared and they come in and they're
like okay here's the the big idea of the
season is X and then we can all start
riffing on that but sometimes you're in
a room where someone literally says to
you what is the season about and you're
like I thought that was your job and so
now you all start riffing trying to come
up with something that the showrunner
latches on to and then it's like okay
that let's talk more about that and then
you can start building it so really the
you know once you start talking about
what those tent poles are and your show
Runners start saying like oh and then
maybe this would be cool at the end of
the season this would be cool like
you're you're building a list of what
might be in the finale but until you
really start getting ready to pitch the
season to the studio and the network
you're more concerned on just making
sure you actually have
6 8 13
uh you know 22 Episodes like that you
know that you're gonna have those
episodes because
you can you know Netflix oftentimes will
ask you to pitch a whole season in three
two to three weeks so you're just in
there basically and and by pitch a
season I mean have big ideas for what
the season is so you're just in there
like okay what if we did an episode
about this and he's like yes write it on
the board like you're just trying to
come up with ideas and half of it will
go away
by the time you actually get to the end
of the season because you're you come up
with better ideas once you have more
time
so yeah I I don't think I've ever
experienced a show where someone was
like
this is how the season ends on the first
day and we were all like so just like
into that it was more like okay how are
we gonna get there
how do you know you have enough story
for the entire season
um
I would say one of the bigger problems
honestly is that you usually have more
story than you have room for like
especially in streaming where you're
only getting eight six to eight ten
episodes
um you will find that there's stuff that
you really want to do that you just
can't get to
because you know
to some of the points that we've talked
about that main character or main
character relationship is going to
always need attention and if you really
need a b story to pay off in the finale
that b story has to keep getting
serviced and so you're going to have
great ideas for things that you want to
do and they're going to stay on a board
for maybe next season because it's just
you end up having more ideas than you
have space for now if you're doing a
season of say SWAT where you've got 22
Episodes
it's it's part of the reason that you
have a room the size that you have for
that right where you have 10 to 12
bodies to just constantly be coming in
being like what if we did an episode
about this what if we did an episode
about that because then you're worried
you won't have enough
um crimes right you can make the
character stories work but it's like you
need 22 crimes what are the 22 crimes
going to be so it's that brainstorming
session of like you know maybe this
maybe this and maybe this and then you
put some down and some of them go away
and some of them become stories you know
and you're always looking when you work
on that type of show you're always
reading newspapers and looking at TV
shows and doing stuff trying to be like
oh what if we did this case and you just
kind of keep a running list because you
never know when like exactly the case
that we were all so excited about we're
like this one's going to be great and
then you try to break it and you're like
oh this isn't an episode
what are we going to do and then you go
to your list
like this one let's do this one
how many story lines are in a typical
season of a show
that's I don't know that I can answer
that because again I think it varies so
much depending on the type of show that
you're doing
um
you know so I wrote on a show called
fate the wing Saga and so we had you
know five girls who were the focus of
our show so each of them has to have
some some sort of story that we're
following right so you know each one of
them has a storyline and then there's a
romantic storyline between our lead and
the handsome boy at the school and then
there's a storyline about the secret
that the teachers are keeping and
it starts to be a lot and it's sort of
the trick is the management of how those
you want those things to all eventually
sort of cross over each other and touch
each other and weave together the
problem is when you suddenly find
yourself with like 10 stories that are
all sort of separate
and and you're like I don't I don't know
like we can't this character's not
participating with any of the other
characters how do we get her involved in
these stories and then you have to like
change the path of that character's art
because you you don't want them on an
island all by themselves you want them
in the main story somehow and part of
that Core group of characters so a lot
of it is I really want to do this for
this character and you'll love the story
but you realize it's pulling them out of
the main Arc and so you have to find a
way to pull them back or you have to
choose different stories for them
how do you structure the story lines
into an episode that's what we call
um blending or weaving or as one of my
show owners love to call it the smush
and that is when you know you have all
your storyline beats out and now you
have to put them in an order that
actually works as an episode of
television and so that's that's a lot of
that you know
um I think this is definitely how I want
to end act three I think this is a great
way to kick off Act five I think
um you know we really want this
relationship turmoil to start in act two
and then boil over in act four so like
you're just sort of trying to figure out
the rhythm of the episode and it's a lot
of moving cards around or changing
things on a whiteboard or moving your
electronic cards but you finally kind of
get a feel for
okay this this works this is an episode
because you're looking out for all kinds
of things right you want your main
characters can't disappear for too long
so if you find that like they're at the
top of act two and then we don't see our
main characters again to like the middle
of act three that's a problem so now you
gotta go rearrange some stuff
um you want to make sure that you're
tracking the stories enough so that no
one's like they're just not going to
talk about that thing anymore so like
even for your c-story Runner that's only
three beats it's like okay if we launch
it in act two and then we need to touch
it in like four and six to pay it off so
that you're not just forgetting about it
so it's it's that kind of balancing act
it's like you're trying to make sure
that you're giving the audience a good
flow of information through the episode